gay people are soon gonna be able to
reproduce without members of the
opposite sex what's that sound that's
Rick Santorum's head exploding same-sex
couples may soon be able to have
children that are genetically related to
both parents dr. jacob hanna discovered
that it is entirely possible to use skin
stem cells from two adults to make a
human egg and human sperm cells the team
believes same-sex couples could seek
this treatment in as little as two years
however researchers did know that it
will be easier for two males to produce
a child as it is more complex to use two
women cells due to the Y chromosome all
right so the big argument that you
always hear from the anti-gay people is
well it can't be natural because they
can't procreate well here comes science
it's a beautiful thing right saurians
yeah but they're not going to they're
not going to accept science right oh
yeah no they'll come up with something
else
yeah probably no this is such a
fascinating thing and such an exciting
thing for me I I get out a little bit
talking about like prenatal genetic
modifications and what that means
socially for us there was a book that
was required reading when I was in
coming as a freshman and it was called
the case against perfection written by
this guy Michael Sandel who's one of the
foremost living philosophers and he has
this whole case that you know we we all
want our kids to be as advantaged as
possible we pay for private schools we
pay for tutors we pay for the best
coaches why wouldn't we if given the
opportunity or availability of
Technology pre net prenatally choose
genetics based on what's going to make
them the most advantaged yeah and the
problem with that becomes that you know
maybe of the society becomes even more
unequal than it's ever been and all that
but this is getting a little off track
but I feel like you I know you're going
to where he was it's a so this is like a
cross between like Gattaca and a brave
new world short I mean I think that what
we look is if that's incredibly exciting
to see these advances happen in science
and I think it's incredible that now
families can really be complete in this
way it seems amazing but to me like the
advances that are happening in science
are happening so fast and so radically
that uh really it's the sky is the limit
for what is possible I mean when you
think about like what Molly's talking
about about really genetically making
your kids so that they can be better at
ports are better at finance or be
doctors or even rich or poor there's
genes for these things that are
determining and I think it's an
incredibly exciting time to be alive
right now for what's possible for me
I've just wanted the wooly mammoth to
come back so I feel like if you can do
this you can bring the mammoths back you
want Jurassic Park you attica figure it
out well Jurassic world's coming this
summer so great I can't wait this ah
maybe it's possible but to your to your
point a lot of this though has to do
with economics and I think that's what
people don't realize that yes we're
gonna have this super set of people this
1% of people that will to afford all
these things and then they're just gonna
grow up with every advantage and that's
gonna separate the 1% from the 99% even
more actually I think the more
interesting question is what makes us so
uncomfortable morally with the idea of
being able to do that prenatally versus
postnatally like there's no moral
dilemma about oh go send your kid to
private school for most people rather
than just getting them tutors when
they're 2 years old on but morally we
get into this interesting question of
playing with like why is it more why is
it more unacceptable to think about
providing your kid with those advantages
before they're born right I think we'll
just apply morals to the primordial stew
of yeah I think the over son or a friend
has a company that's that's growing
diamonds.they culture these diamonds
meaning they you know grow them from a
sliver of diamond and they're impossible
to tell a cultured diamond a grown
diamond from a real diamond you cannot
detect it or tell it with microscopes
with any sort of lasers with anything
and to me that's this incredibly
fascinating argument where you say what
is that what is the difference now what
is nature what is grown in a laboratory
I think we're about to face it with all
of this a synthetic meat that's about to
come out where people are growing all of
our next generation of hamburgers and
hot dogs are all doing many many stories
I'm obsessed with that guy stuff because
I can't believe that people do I pee or
you're about to ask these questions big
ethical big moral questions are starting
to be coming to play out you know it's
what Elon must just gave a lot of money
to put some rules in place for AI
because we're gonna have to start
governing things that we never knew we
needed to govern in the past you knew he
was going to bring it back to a totally
a little shorter so what would if you
had the option
of picking between a set of ten embryos
for your child yeah are there certain
things that you would test for make sure
they don't have any developmental or
physical correcting or would you not
want to know or would you like the money
if I had the money in the means yeah you
would yeah I could make my kid a great
athlete and like be able to dunk I
wanted to dunk and I can't dunk for a
lot of us we look at you know simple
things like Alzheimer's you know which
is there's an easy way to detect the
genetics for that and I think that you
know many of us would would want to
choose our child so they don't have all
time but I think there's a difference
also between the active and the passive
choosing right if you're just sorting
out for things that are developmental
problems right versus actively selecting
for like athletics ISM or a certain eye
color or hair color or maybe even sexual
preference at some point which gets into
a really interesting conversation let's
wrap this up with the sexual preference
part of this the gay thing happened
pretty quick and by that I mean like the
right thing this like these last five
years are you shocked at how quickly
this has happened like it's almost
behind us and I will be literally the
happiest person on earth when it's
behind us because gays just want equal
rights not bonus right I think that it's
been incredibly exciting just to see
what's you know it's like the old forest
for the trees thing I think it's been
incredibly exciting to see all of our
social advancements that we've had in
the last five years I mean it's been
amazing whether it's gay rights you know
the right to marry or whether it's been
even loosening of marijuana and drug
laws that you're seeing I mean we're
really Ledbetter Fair Pay Act yeah I
mean where we have an extremely long way
to go but I think that we're making
advances that we won't fully see until
we're looking back at a 10-year period
and go wow that was a that was a time
that that this country and the the world
really stepped some leaps forward yeah
and what does it say in the Bible
something about gays being stoned which
not a problem because of a legalized